normalement une optique signer ça coûte
un bras voilà 2 3 plein plein de bras
mais celle dont je vous parlais
aujourd'hui et coûte moins de 300 euros
alors est ce qu'à ce prix là ça vaut
vraiment le coup et est ce que ça fait
de belles images mais je vais essayer
j'ai filmé des trucs et je vais vous les
montrer mais juste après l'intro bien
sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mme
encore je suis ravi comme à chaque vidéo
de vous retrouver sur cette chaîne dans
laquelle on parle de tout ce qui est en
lien avec la vidéo
donc si vous vous intéressez à la vidéo
ben je pense que vous pouvez envisager
deux vous abonner de cliquer sur le
petit bouton qui se situe juste en
dessous aujourd'hui je vous parlais
d'une optique qui m'intriguait depuis
pas mal de temps et que du coup j'ai eu
envie de tester je précise que ce serait
une review absolument pas scientifique
j'ai pas fait de mesure j'ai juste
utiliser la chose dans des vraies
conditions et j'ai voulu vous en parler
parce que j'ai trouvé ça intéressant
cette vidéo n'est pas sponsorisé voilà
je les ai achetés avec mesut cette
optique c'est un 58 mm f/2 2 chez iron
glace et hors glace qu'il fait enfin bon
c'est pas vraiment iron glace qu'il a
fait d'ailleurs c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué que ça je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi
en fait cette optique elle a été recalée
au c c'est à dire que on a gardé tous
les éléments optiques de l'intérieur
c'est-à-dire le vert & or je sais pas
exactement quel parti ils ont gardé mais
ils ont gardé
voilà l'essence de l'optique de base et
iron glace a refait tout l'extérieur je
vous montre voilà tout ce qui est métal
tout ce qui est les bagues etc
le cash voilà tout et tout est refait
par ailleurs noblesse alors quel besoin
de refaire me direz vous et bien tout
simplement parce que l'optique de base
qui a à l'intérieur le la partie
verrerie et tout ça à la base leur petit
nom c'est hélios 44,2 ce sont des
optiques soviétique c'est des trucs qui
date 1 s'est relativement vieux et on
les trouve pour une cinquantaine d'euros
les originales des fois sur ebay mais on
les trouve dans l'état c'est à dire
qu'avec les montures qui sont pas
équivalentes aux montures moderne il
faut jouer avec des bagues et où il ya
moyen de s'en tirer pour moins cher que
chez iron glace mais faudra bidouiller
un petit peu quand même
là ces prêts à l'emploi le fabricant le
fait sur toutes les montures qui existe
et vous allez me dire mais pourquoi
françois tu nous parles de cette optique
et bien parce que cette optique elle a
plein de défauts certes mais elle a
aussi plein de choses que j'aime
beaucoup et le premier truc qui m'a
séduit dans cette optique là c'est que
justement il y en a pas deux dans la
même série qui sont exactement les mêmes
je vous explique les procédés de
fabrication aujourd'hui sont hyper
précis et entre deux optiques moderne va
y avoir une petite différence on n'a
jamais vraiment deux fois la même
optique mais elles vont être minime sur
les hélios comme ça ben les techniques
étaient un peu moins pointu à l'époque
de fabrication ce qui fait que on a des
différences quand même
relativement notable entre les
différentes pièces d'une même série et
ça c'est peut-être psychologique mais
j'aimais bien le fait de me dire voilà
si j'ai une optique un petit peu unique
puisque toutes les optiques un tout les
hélios et bien elles vont pas être
exactement pareil elles vont avoir la
même focale et tout il n'ya pas une
différence de rendu ouf issime mais
voilà iai
ce petit côté unique l'autre chose que
j'aime bien et que vous avez pu voir
dans la petite vidéo d'intro c'est
qu'elle a un bouquet très particulier
déjà la forme des petits halo de lumière
il est beaucoup moins en rond que les
optiques que j'utilise d'habitude qui
sont très très bien aussi mais voilà ça
change un petit peu ya un petit truc qui
fait que c'est sympa le bloc est alors
il y en a qui trouvent qu'il ya une
espèce de débloquer un peu tournoyant
alors moi j'ai pas vraiment vraiment vu
ça sur les vidéos mais bon j'ai pas
filmé dans tout un tas de situations
j'ai juste voilà testé dans les
conditions que vous et montrez mais ça
nous amène surtout au fait qu' elle a un
côté très organique plein de petits
défauts des petits frères des petites
des petites déformations et je trouve
cool en fait ces défauts alors comme
vous avez pu le voir il ya aussi des
bagues ici donc on a une bague de mise
au point qui est ici et une vague
d'ouverture qui est là qui va nous
permettre d'ouvrir plus ou moins grand
notre diaphragme et vous l'avez bien
compris elle est 100% manuel ya zéro
électronique donc pas d'autofocus un
bien entendu c'est un focus manuel
uniquement
bien entendu il n'y a pas de
stabilisation non plus c'est vraiment du
lot du brute de chez brute comme je vous
le dis sur la focale on est sur du 58 mm
plein format donc elle va être plus à
l'aise sur du portrait que sur du
paysage ou de l' architecture bien
entendu et jusqu'à présent j'avais
utilisé du 52 85 ou dézoomer 58,7 une
focale que j'avais jamais vraiment testé
est la différence entre 50 et 58 mais
est ce sens c'est un tout petit peu plus
serré qu un 50 mm et encore une fois ça
donne un côté un petit peu atypique à
cette optique assez rigolo parce qu'en
fait je cite plein de défauts de
l'optique et je vous dis que
après ci est clairement c'est ça en fait
dans cette vidéo je vais vous lister
tous les défauts de l'optique
mais les défauts que lui donne son
charme un autre défaut que ce toxique
peut avoir c'est qu'elle va être
beaucoup moins sharp beaucoup moins
n'être qu'une optique moderne une
optique moderne vraiment on aura des
détails on aura quelque chose d'hyper
précis là faut pas compter être dans la
précision extrême c'est des optiques qui
ont au mieux une trentaine d'années
voilà un petit peu des antiquités quand
même mais comme je vous le disais dans
la vidéo que j'avais faite sur les
filtres de diffusion va en vidéo des
fois on n'a pas envie que ce soit trop
nets soit rochard en photo clairement
oui c'est un gros atout en vidéo pas
toujours d'ailleurs j'utilisais un
filtre de diffusion sur les extraits que
vous avez pu le voir pour accentuer
encore plus le côté un petit peu vintage
et profiter au maximum des flair en
ajoutant un petit peu de glo fin voilà
c'était vraiment le rendu que j'avais
envie d'avoir alors par contre un défaut
qu'il a pour le coup bon ça reste de
l'optique pas cher mais c'est un défaut
que j'ai pas qui fait plus que ça c'est
que j'ai pas pigé en fait y'a pas de
marqueur en fait sur les bagues pour
savoir en fait hacker l'ouverture on est
où on se situe dans la mise au point
donc c'est du pifomètre total dont on
sait que voilà il ya trop de lumière je
ferme un petit peu il n'y a pas assez de
lumière j'ouvre un petit peu mais je je
sais que je suis au max à la butte et
d'un côté comme de l'autre mais entre
les deux on sait pas vraiment où on est
ou alors j'ai pas compris
et idem pour la mise au point on sait
qu'on est au point le plus près quand on
a la butée et on sait qu'on est allé
infinie quand on est à l'autre but est
donc là-dessus niveau précision rajoute
encore un petit challenge protos pas
trop où on est sage avoue avoir un petit
point rouge pour savoir où on en est ça
coûtait pas grand chose et ça aurait été
quand même bienvenu
maintenant je suis pas en train de vous
dire il faut absolument que vous achetez
cette optique là parce que elle est
utilisable dans certains cas uniquement
là clairement quand je vais utiliser
j'avais le temps je faisais ma mise au
point manuelle tranquillement mais si on
doit filmer quelque chose qui va vite un
reportage où il faut saisir des moments
voilà très important qu'on pourra pas
reproduire clairement pas ce type de
petit claque il faut utiliser vraiment
pas là vous allez droit dans le mur
à moins de l'utiliser à à faible
ouverture et là bon ça peut se gérer
mais ce pas une optique qui est hyper
pratique à utiliser
c'est par run and gun c'est pas loppsi
qui va vous sauver la vie clairement pas
mais cette optique mois trouve qu'elle a
une dimension
artistique c'est à dire que elle crée
une ambiance elle crée ce petit côté
organique que j'ai vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup apprécié dans l'utilisation les
petits frères les petites déformations
les tous ces trucs là en fait j'ai
trouvé que ça donnait vraiment un cachet
assez ou fall optique donc clairement
pas l'optique à avoir mais si vous avez
envie de vous faire plaisir sur une
optique foule manuel pour démarrer pour
pas trop cher et ben je pense que c'est
une bonne porte d'entrée
mais pour conclure il ya quand même un
truc totalement naze sur cette optique
là mais vraiment vraiment naze c'est
tout simplement le mot ce ciné c'est pas
une optique siné était une optique rck a
rossé avec des grosses bagues
qu'effectivement on peut monter sur
n'importe quelle caméra et grâce aux
bagues on va pouvoir utiliser un polo
focus fin c'est oui oui ok mais est ce
que c'est une optique pour le cinéma
pas certain que ce soit une optique plus
pour le cinéma qu'une autre c'est sûr
que dans tous les cas c'est pas une
optique photo même si on peut faire des
photos avec bien sûr mais c'est pas
destiné à la photo moi si je devais
donner une catégorie pour cette optique
c'est une optique vidéo vintage avec du
cachet est très intéressante à
travailler donc si vous avez apprécié
cette petite découverte une optique un
petit peu exotique et bien vous
n'hésitez pas à mettre le traditionnel
coup deux masters sur le pouce en l'air
qui se situe juste en dessous de cette
vidéo puis moi je vous dis les amis
comme d'habitude rester curieux et à
très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
je profite de cette fin de vidéo où tous
les vrais reste pour vous souhaiter à
tous d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année
soyez prudent surtout en ce moment
profitez bien gâter vos proches
et puis moi je vais faire une petite
pause d'octroyer des petites vacances et
on se retrouve en 2021
pour toujours plus de vidéos pour
toujours plus de conseils de tests
d'astuces bref ça va être cool 2021
on y croit